I think we one step away first because
you know sir platter says he's gonna
sort fifa I personally don't think he
can or he will and the kind of attitude
he's adopted since last Friday I think
shows the you know he wants to just
brazen out and consequently that's one
of the first things i think the prime
minister should do is get all the
broadcaster's the sponsors and the
football associations of the home
nations sitting around a table together
to form a common road busty british
position and and then and then get the
other countries in europe on board as
well for a UEFA and possible and when
you want to call it boycott or setting
up an alternative competition i don't
mind well yes because i will need the
support of other nations won't it have
you been without goodness if we try to
go ahead on our own Greg Dyke is
absolutely right and I think those who
call for an immediate British boycott as
it were or an England boycott for 2018 I
think a mistaken it's much better to
bring that lots of countries together
but how much support is that likely to
get bearing in mind the amount of
support that set Blatter had in his
reelection well he had a significant
amount of a report of support but you
got to remember that it's quite a few of
the countries in Latin America can't
have voted for him most of the countries
in Europe and I think that they were I'm
sure that if the British prosecuting
authorities are doing their job properly
which I hope they are John Whittingdale
didn't answer on this today in the House
of Commons if they're doing their job
properly I suspect there'll be more
charges to come and set Blatter's
position will become completely
untenable I think is that it's untenable
to us now but I think you'll become more
transparently so to others you talked
about several strands there you talked
about wanting answers as far as sponsors
are concerned and also broadcasters as
well start with sponsors I mean do you
feel that that's where the most traction
can be felt if you like I mean money
talks in this game of course but I'm
amazed how mealy-mouthed some of the
sponsors have been I mean do they not
realize I thought the whole point of
sponsorship was that you identified your
brand with a popular brand well if the
world cup is such a damaged tainted
corrupt brand I can only imagine that
it's not going to do FIFA visa
coca-cola nike McDonald's it's not going
to do their brands any favor so I think
they should be much more robust than the
Prime Minister should get them in for a
summit and tell them look you are
damaging your own business here if you
if you if you stick with FIFA and I mean
maybe Gazprom you know the Russian gas
energy company is used to that kind of
dodgy brand but we're not and we and if
people are going to go and buy
McDonald's burgers and buy nike shoes
they may well argue they want to see
where these investigations lead first
what about the broadcaster so that was
the other thing that you mentioned yes
so I asked Whittingdale last week can he
be absolutely sure that no licence fee
payers money has gone into anybody's
back pocket and and of course he hasn't
answered that question yet I think
there's a really important issue here
because are we really expecting that
licence fee payers money should go
towards and the rights for the 2018 and
the 2022 World Cup because in which case
it's our money going straight into
somebody else's dodgy back pocket I
think Whittingdale should sit down with
all his European colleagues who also
have license fees in Germany in Italy
and Spain and all the rest of it or
whether state subsidy and should say no
there will be no state funding going to
FIFA okay Kris Bryant thank you thank
you